hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast characterizing the
performance of qpcr instruments
approaches for assessment in comparison
and Brenda Kelly Kelly of lab roots and
I'll be a moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring this
educational web seminar presented by lab
booths and sponsored by Douglas
scientific Douglas scientific LLC is a
rapidly growing laboratory automation
company located in exam Alexandria
Minnesota with the team of over 100
professionals bringing together
expertise and engineering Biosciences
automation motion control and other
fields core to the deathless scientific
mission is a dedication to making the
world of water place by delivering
innovative laboratory automation the
more information please visit www is
designed to be interactive and we
encourage you to ask questions during
the event you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button the lower left of the
presentation window will try to answer
as many questions as we can you can
enlarge the slide window by clicking on
the screen icon in the lower right hand
corner the slide window if you have any
technical problems viewing or hearing
this presentation please click on the
sport button or submit your problem
through the 3d Q&A button lower left
before we begin I would like to let our
audience to know that you will soon see
a poll question popping up on your
screen if you could take a moment to
answer this poll question so that we can
improve the content with learning we
would really appreciate it I would now
like to introduce today's speakers Ross
Figgins and Michael movie stuff Ross
Higgins is a business development
executive leaf-subway scientific who
serves in several capacities related to
the development introduction and growing
adoption of new intelligent system for
qpcr applications before joining a
company frost worked within the clinical
diagnostics field and was responsible
for oversight
the molecular testing laboratory and of
rapidly growing kaif accredited startup
reference laboratory mineral Ross and 15
developed and validated new workflows
and test methods that led to
unprecedented throughput capacity and
cost reductions Ross has a BS in
clinical laboratory science and an MBA
in Virginia Commonwealth University and
maintains an ascp certification as a
medical laboratory scientist dr. Kirby
step is the founder and CCO the ta ta a
bio center ww ta ta a calm and head of
the department of gene expression of the
institute of biotechnology at the Czech
academy of sciences he was one of the
pioneers contributing to the development
of quantitative real-time pcr qpcr and
introduced qpcr for single-cell
expression profile led the development
of reagents for high-throughput single
cell expression profiling and quality
piece control we also developed a qpcr
tomography the intracellular expression
profiling dr. Kirby stefko offered the
minimum information for publication of
quantitative real-time pcr experiments
and I QE guidelines and is a member of
the cen and is over foods drafting
forthcoming technical specifications and
guidelines and the pre analytical
processes and molecular diagnosis
diagnostics I will now turn it over to
Ross Higgins for his presentation Thank
You Brenda I'd like to begin by once
again welcoming everyone to today's
special webinar presentation on the
performance characterization of qpcr
instruments again my name is Ross
Aegon's and on behalf of the entire team
here at Douglas scientific thank you
again for joining us today for those of
you who may not be entirely familiar
with Douglas scientific we are a small
but also rapidly growing laboratory
automation and consumable company and as
Brenda mention
core to our business and our mission is
a dedication to making the world a
better place through the delivery of
innovative laboratory automation
solutions that enable the advancement of
biomolecular research and not only
higher speeds but also fractional costs
and our history in the PCR space really
began with the array tape consumable
which is a unique product that can be
used as a replacement to PCR plates and
microtiter plates and due to the
continuous nature of array tape as
compared to a traditional microtiter
plate it is very well suited for inline
processing and subsequently delivers a
total paradigm shift compared to plate
based processing methods that you might
be familiar with and when combined with
our robust automation instrument
platforms the array tape enables
complete elimination of manual
processing in your lab and subsequently
will allow for an increase in throughput
reduction in labor costs and a
minimization of potential for human
error in your processing and the unique
design of array tape provides a notable
characteristic of supporting very highly
miniaturized PCR reactions as compared
to microtiter plates and this reduces
both your reagent and your sample use as
well as total consumable cost of running
these assays in your laboratory and our
newest product the entelechy was
recently launched earlier this year and
advances all of these benefits to
include a fully integrated PCR workflow
that provides for extreme laboratory
efficiency and we see in tele cube as
the next evolution of our array tape
platform and fully integrating liquid
handling amplification detection and
data analysis steps associated with a
typical PCR workflow all into a single
laboratory system supporting real-time
PCR with the array tape consumable and
as I mentioned in teluk you has been
designed
is a fully integrated system users
simply start by programming their
samples and assays using our intuitive
software and then the technician loads
those DNA samples and they're a safe
weights which would contain pcr reagents
onto the instrument itself and from
there the run or the protocol is
activated through a touchscreen
interface on the instrument and the rest
of the process is fully automated for
true walk away automation typically it
begins by loading 800 nanometers of each
sample and assay into the reaction Wells
within a given segment of a rate eight
this combines to create a total of a 1.6
microliter PCR reaction which is then
sealed and the array itself is moved
into the integrated PCR station on the
instrument for thermal cycling excellent
block performance ensures minimal well
too well variation in your PCR reactions
across the array and as the block goes
through each pcr cycle the dyes are
excited through LEDs on the instrument
and the real-time fluorescence is
monitored through an onboard CCD camera
in the system and I think users will
find that the entelechy will support
nearly any of the commonly used pcr
probes and fluorogenic dies in a PCR
reaction as the instrument
completing a typical PCR protocol users
can either monitor the progress of their
run in real time or once the run is
complete our telly score software will
allow them to access their data and
analyze or export to a lens system or a
new another program such as Gen X for
downstream analysis introducing intelli
cube the process begins with independent
aspiration of the DNA sample and
reagents from the respective source
plates source plates can be randomly
accessed through the plate stacker
located on the instrument the DNA
samples are dispensed in up to 384 wells
at one time with the ciebie felix
dispense pipette following sample
dispensing into the array tape reagents
are loaded into the wells the array is
automatically sealed with a pressure
sensitive seal prior to thermal cycling
in the meantime integrated wash stations
are used to clean the tips and provide
stringent cleaning measures to mitigate
the risk of cross-contamination between
samples if healthy a black facilitates
the amplification and supports multiple
array formats without blocked changes
real-time fluorescence detection is
supported with the high-resolution ccd
camera and LED excitation source with
five optic channels and the ability to
multiplex data capture in 15 seconds or
less
the intelex software supports protocol
generation and subsequent data analysis
of PCR results lab personnel can observe
amplification curves on the instrument
in real-time walk away operation
increased efficiency of lab personnel
increase throughput reduce chemistry
costs and reduce consumable costs
intelli cube your solution for the most
efficient lab possible so as you saw in
the video together with array tape the
intelligent form provides users a fully
integrated system that eliminates
error-prone workflows and complex
automation it provides flexibility for a
range of throughput needs different
chemistry selections as well as
customizable dispensing patterns for
various study designs and perhaps most
importantly it provides both of these
key benefits in an efficient and
economical manner that will reduce labor
and reagent use in your lab allowing you
to achieve the lowest possible operating
costs for your qPCR workflows and that
brings me to the last topic that not
really fully addressed yet which is qPCR
instrument performance it's not hard to
argue that very few platforms offer a
combination of flexibility low cost of
operation and high performance
frequently it seems like you might be
left with an exercise of picking two of
those but not usually three and
performance may very well be the most
difficult topic of all to address
because of the many different parameters
involved and notably the lack of
standardization between vendors which
makes it difficult to compare different
instruments to each other however with
the support of Michael cubist and his
colleagues at tata we generated
extensive performance data on the
intelligent system and it convinces me
personally that the middle of this
diagram could actually be occupied by a
respectable new platform from Douglas
site
fake but the data will speak louder than
words and certainly louder than me so
from here I'd like to thank you for your
attention as I welcome Michael cubist
Michael will be discussing some of the
important instrument performance
parameters as well as some practical
approaches that can be used by your lab
to assess and compare qpcr performance
Thank You Douglas for the introduction
tada bio center researchers been working
in the pcr field since 1991 starting out
developing dyes and probes that become
force in the combining DNA in 1998 we
found in the first company europe
specialized in real-time pcr based micro
diagnostics in 2001 the Tata bio centers
were founded our headquarter is in
Gothenburg Sweden we are also present in
Prague supplicant and San Francisco
working time to his leading instrument
and solution providers we had the best
equipped laboratories for molecular
analysis where we offer hands-on
training there are also one of Europe's
leading providers of molecular services
and we are behind many of the quality
control methods and tools currently on
the market implications of poor quality
control can be detrimental as
illustrated by Leeson case in german for
over two years germany investigators
were searching for a serial killer who
based on DNA evidence was linked to six
homicides DNA tests revealed the killer
was female running through crime
databases the elusive killer was found
acted all around German and was also
linked to 40 crimes including common pet
car dealership robbery and school
breaking the suspect was eventually
identified it was a female technician
from the production of the swamps the
cotton swabs used were not certified for
DNA analysis
in 2002 a scientific report linked
measles vaccine towards the supporting
data were based on quantitative
real-time pcr the actual data are shown
in the graph to the left or positive
standard samples and to the right we see
patient samples interpreted as positive
by the investigative the interpretation
of the qpcr data was called into
question by dr. Steven busting who
appeared as expert witness for the
defense in the united states and federal
claims in washington DC when the vaccine
police received the publication was
retracted and the news were spray but it
was too late people had lost confidence
in the vaccine leading to measles
outbreak all across the world sometimes
eden is deadly out loud how could such
questionable qpcr data and up in the
prestigious journal causing so much harm
this question was asked by Steven Buster
gather the group of experts in the qpcr
fear and together we wrote the Mikey
guidelines the mighty guidelines request
papers presenting keepin CRS aisles to
provide validation data and sufficient
information about the experiment for the
reviewers to be able to assess the
quality compliance was the Mikey
guidelines as today requested by over 25
journals and recommended by many more in
Diagnostics quality requirements are
even higher since treatment decisions
may be based on the test result in the
diagnostic workflow most of the issues
the elite uncertainty variability and
bias or introduced during the pre
analytical work flow rather than by the
action molecular analysis this led the
European Commission to launch the
project Stevie under the coronation of
courage
for standardized and improve the pre
annika workflow objectives included
identifying factors was impact on test
results and to develop technologies and
tools to control the workflow and assess
the quality of the material being tested
speedier activities included proficiency
of introns samples were shared among
participating laboratories across Europe
that were instructed to prepare DNA or
RNA using their standard operating
procedures and return the purified
nucleic acid to us a quality assessment
on to more than 100 participating
routine laboratory 33-percent had at
least two quality indicators out of
range when analyzing RNA based on the
problems identified and addressed in
studio the European Committee for
Standardization Sam initiated in 2010
the program to develop technical
specifications for the pre analytical
processing of samples are about to be
published in 2014 the International
Organization for Standardization ISO
launched a project to address the
Priyanka fails in molecular diagnostics
the force coming guidelines are related
to the analysis of RNA and snap frozen
tissue the analysis of protein instead
frozen tissue the analysis of DNA and
FFP tissue the analysis of RNA in FFP
tissue the analysis of protein in FFP
tissue the analysis of RNA in blood
samples the analysis of genomic DNA in
blood samples and the analysis of
cell-free DNA in 137 countries
participating in the ice record and an
additional 20 countries or observing
this map indicates if the guidelines
apply to your country so what have we
learned from speedy on my key and from
internal QC earth I will take you
through how is
performance allele systems at our bio
Center and as example we will evaluate
entelechy from value scientific the same
procedure is used to evaluate the
performance of any new diagnostic test
you will say new reagent matches and
even when introducing a new technician
we start by testing the uniformity and
repeatability of the system essentially
invalidating the comparable results are
obtained in all the wells on the
interview we then evaluate the dynamic
range efficient in precision on the test
we evaluate the limit of quantification
which is the lowest amount of target
that can be quantified we also evaluate
a limit of detection which is the lowest
amount of target that can be detected
unnecessarily time finally we assess
their a solution which is a smallest
concentration difference that can I
mention to test the performance we need
a test to say the most popular test to
say for this purpose is the valid plan
originally developed by Henry Corral it
to loose University to measure and
correct for a sigil genomic DNA in
expression profiling stands blooded
prime is a highly optimized sa targeting
a non transcribed conserved sequence in
the human genome that is present in
exactly one copy per haply genome the
valid prime is used was a genomic DNA
standard calibrated against the National
Institute of Standards and Technology
human genomic DNA standard reference
material hence working with valid prime
we determine the absolute number of
human genomes the test sample in gene
expression profiling but if prime offers
a smoother more accurate and much more
cost efficient workflow than arti-
controls for compensation genomic DNA
back it is critical replicate
measurements generate same race on any
variation across replicate mission ins
confound the measured results and may
limit the
illusions that can be made based on the
analysis instrument companies usually
specified uniformity and repeatability
of their instruments by the coefficient
of variation which is usually around one
percent this information has to be
converted into something that can be
mission and experimentally validated if
the specification is that a coefficient
of variation shall be no more than one
percent at cycling time this means the
standard deviation of replicates shall
be no more than point from nine cycles
so let's see how mean chaliki performs
filling the plate of the in telugu with
replicates quantifying genomic DNA with
a valid Primus say we can inspect and
quantifying the repeatability as you see
in this graph the 768 replicate qpcr
response curves very time this is a
frequency diagram showing the
distribution of the CQ values across the
768 replicates the data are analyzed was
a QC tool in the software channels the
first test is for normality which passes
meaning that the variation of CQ values
across the replicas is normal
distributed which is expected the
standard deviation of the replicates is
also calculated and is here point zero
eight seven cycles this is far below the
point to point 25 cycles claimed by the
majority of chickens or instrument
writers do all instruments performed as
well not really this is an example for
one of our regular QC controls at the
Tata BIOS and as you see this test
passes normality however the standard
deviation is unacceptably high it is
point 45 cycles
was this instrument we would never be
able to reliably measure small
differences we found a filter in this
instrument was offset which may have
happened by somebody accidentally
bouncing into it the line in the filter
instant instrument eventually performed
well again notably there was no message
or any other indication from the
instrument it was now performing to
discover the problem we need it to the
phone the QC scan this is another
example of an outperforming qpcr
instrument this time the standard
deviation is within specification so
although just barely it's point 2 4 6
but inspecting the distribution of CQ
values we see it is not normal rather
there are two peaks this particular
instrument had two liters one on each
side of the blog the peels air heating
elements were not synchronized resulting
in a small temperature difference
between the two sides of the law this
gave rise to a systematic difference in
CQ values and the B modal distribution
was observed replacing the
malfunctioning pelletier element the
instrument worked ok again as was the
previous example there was no error
message and we might not have discovered
the problem without performing the QC
test from experience we have learned
importance of regularly validating the
performance all the QP sentiments to use
the valley prime or rather genomic DNA
is not suitable template for evaluating
dynamic range because they cannot work
is high concentrations of the Eugene all
due to viscosity of issues for this we
need a different test to say we will use
in the thin tepic double-stranded DNA
template a one thousand base pairs alien
sequence this DNA spy is popular to test
and optimize the performance of
workflows as it reflects inhibition and
yield
a static curve is constructed by
analyzing standard samples containing
between point five and forty million
copies of the DNA is five the standard
samples are constructed by tenfold
serial dilution the calibrated stock
inspecting the static curve we see the
variation across replicates increases
towards higher CPU which corresponds to
lower concentration we also see that the
lowest concentration C cules far below
the trend line indicating a bias this is
even clearer in the residuals plot which
shows the deviation from the trend line
as function of template concentration at
the lowest concentration we have an
average of any point for molecules for
reaction volume so many of the replicas
are negative which is the reason for the
bias it is expected also the largest
spread and lower concentration is
expected this is due to a phenomenon
known as sampling ambiguity consider
patient infected by influenza virus
having a load of one iron molecule per
milliliter block if we connect one mil
of blood from that patient this
particular meal may contain one iron
molecule but it may also contain two
three or perhaps even for and there is
also a distinct the possibility the
particular mill of blood collected
contains no virus at all and we obtain a
negative test result the probabilities
for those outcomes are given by the
force or distribution which is depicted
in this crap the purple line indicates
the probabilities for the accomplish a
scale the probability a sampling of one
mill contains exactly one molecule when
collected from the container as an
average concentration of one molecule
premiere is thirty-seven percent the
probability it contains two molecules is
eight
in person and it is seven percent it
contains three the probability this
blank is also service at understand this
variation across replicants due to
sampling ambiguity give rise to the
impression to the imprecision and the
quantification of low concentrated
samples from the france or distribution
we can calculate the theoretical limit
of detection this graph indicates the
probability a sampling is posted as a
function of target concentration in the
container from the graph follows an
average of three target molecules per
volume on a line is required to produce
ninety-five percent positive readings
hence working at ninety-five percent
confidence the theoretical limit of
detection due to sampling ambiguities
three molecules note this limit of
detection is independent of the
measurement technology the sampling
ambiguity also contributes to the
largest spread of replicas towards lower
template concentrations and as seen in
this example there is no generally
agreed acceptable spread of replicas for
quantification it values from case to
case depending on the precision
requested for the particular test at
tata unless me and other specifications
we request the relative standard
deviation also known as the coefficient
of variation of the estimated
concentrations to be less than thirty
five percent the limit of quantification
shall also be within the dynamic range
of the test and it cannot be below the
limit of detection this is the loq
analysis of the DNA spike data the
lowest template concentration that falls
below thirty five percent relative
standard deviation is forty molecules
hence
the quantification is at least 40
template molecules but it is not as good
as for which is a concentration of the
next standard form this is again the
standard curve of the DNA's find this
time however we have eliminated the
concentrations below the ll q showing
only the linear range as you can see in
this range the replicas of very time
from the slope of the standard curve we
estimate the PCR deficiency which for
this assay is ninety three point six
percent because of the very high
reproducibility of the instrument and
the large number of replicates that can
be perform the efficiency is determined
with very high precision the ninety-five
percent confidence interval is 93.1 to
ninety-four percent which means we
really know is very high accuracy the
piece on efficiency of this assay and we
can make the live of Corrections the
precision of the standard curve is
reflected by the working hotlink
confidence back that indicates where the
standard curve is expected to be with
ninety-five percent confidence the
working ha telling confidence band is
indicated by red dashed lines one on
each side of the fitted static showed
was the blue line without enlarging the
graph you cannot distinguish the red and
blue lines indicating exceeding
precision and the estimated standing as
mentioned before was valid trying we
cannot produce tana curves covering a
wide range of concentrations because of
limitations working with genomic DNA
this valid prime standard curve
therefore covers a narrower
concentration range but instead it is
based on much smaller increments the
dilution you need step here is only two
hole
analyzing the spread of the replicates
for the valid primer saying we find the
limit of quantification of 32 molecules
or lower with 16 molecules the
coefficient of variation of the
estimated concentrations is just about
thirty-five percent so loq is somewhere
between 16 and 32 molecules these data
can also be analyzed for the limit of
detection at low target concentrations
replicates become negative this plot
shows the fraction of negative calls
versus concentration entering the graph
sorry entering the graph at ninety-five
percent we read out the limit of
detection to two point 95 molecules as
you recall this is the theoretical limit
of detection meaning the confounding
variation here is entirely you in the
sampling am beating re plotting the
standard curve for the valid primacy
above the limit of quantification we
cover the range from 32 to 2048
molecules from this plot we estimate the
PCR efficiency of the valid primacy to
99.7 percent was ninety-five percent
confidence of 98 to 100 2% the somewhat
wider confidence interval here compared
to the analysis of the DNA Spy is due to
the narrower concentration range cover
finally we also test for a solution
again the valid primer say was use but
this time half of the replicates had
fifty percent higher concentration in
the plot these are shown in blue color
and found at lower CQ
additional plots show concentration
differences of thirty percent
twenty-five percent twenty percent and
fifteen percent as the concentration
difference decreases the blue and brown
response curves move closer together the
resolution can be quantified as follows
the spread of seek use of the replicants
at each of the two concentrations that
are compared is plotted in a frequency
diagram a decision line is drawn in
between the two Maxima that should
distinguish between samples at the two
concentration the number of replicates
at each concentration that could you
will see cues on the one side of the
decision line are misclassified based on
the test working at ninety-five percent
confidence a maximum of five percent
false calls is tolerating this
corresponds to a tests specificity and
test sensitivity or ninety-five percent
or higher so let's see you how the
measured data behaved this type with
fifty percent difference in
concentration corresponding to full
change 1.5 we have complete separation
of the replicants at the tooth
concentration with 30 percent difference
in concentrations distributions move
closer and there is some overlap
specificity is now ninety-eight percent
and sensitivity is ninety-nine percent
specificity and sensitivity firmly
relates to the rates of positive the
negative cases since we here compared to
concentrations only the naming is
arbitrary moving to twenty five percent
difference we have a specificity of
ninety-eight percent and a sensitivity
of one hundred percent continuing to
twenty percent difference we have a
specificity of ninety-eight percent and
a sensitivity of ninety-seven percent
and at a concentration difference of
fifteen percent we have a specificity of
ninety-eight percent and a sensitivity
of eighty-six percent the letter has
more than five percent false calls which
means the resolution is not sufficient
anymore to distinguish between the two
concentration to summarize the results
we have obtained in the validation study
on the in telugu using the valid Prime
and calibrated women genomic DNA we have
found the piece yard efficiency of the
valid Primus a run on the in telugu is
99.7 percent with a ninety-five percent
confidence interval 97.7 to 101.7
percent the limit of detection of
genomic DNA with a valid primer say on
the in telugu is three molecules which
corresponds to the theoretical limit due
to sampling ambiguity the limit of
quantification of genomic DNA with a
valid primer saying on the in telugu at
thirty-five percent relative standard
deviation is between 16 and 32 molecules
the resolution using the valid primacy
on the intelligent sufficient to measure
twenty percent difference in the
concentration of genomic DNA using the
DNA spy we find the dynamic range is 44
40 million target molecules and the
piece shot efficiency is 19
three-point-four percent note the
impressive occur see in the estimate of
the piece you're efficient the
ninety-five percent confidence in
it's 93% 293 on eight percent all these
analysis have been performed in
compliance with the clsi guidelines as
implement in the software channels from
aldi's i have taken through with the
scanning procedure to assess a new
system in this case in teluk you from
douglas scientific the same approach can
be used to assess any more system test
kit say or just to validate a new batch
of reagents if you're interested
learning more about the methods to
design optimize and validate molecular
analysis you are welcome to join any of
the Tata I'll center hands-on courses we
offer I thank you for your attention and
we will be happy to take your questions
thank you Michael and Ross for that
excellent presentation before we get
started on questions I'd like to remind
our audience just how they can submit
their questions you can submit questions
by typing them into the Q&A box which
can be found as I said clicking on the
green Q&A button lower left of the
presentation window will try to answer
as many questions as we have time for
our first question is for dr. Freda
stuff how did the performance
characterization compared to other
leading qpcr and streams interestingly
very few instrument manufacturers share
performance data on their instrument the
information and the specifications is
usually very limited and of course one
can do it internally and we do it but to
a certain extent and but generally the
specifications of most of the qpcr
instruments is as I indicated a
coefficient of variation of one percent
for the repeatability which corresponds
to standard deviations of 0 point 25
because this is typically specified
25 cycles recently Roche launched their
new system and with a little better
specification which is point 22 standard
deviation so the Intel acute at least in
our hands performs better than at least
those specifications then of course
there are systems for research that are
not really commercial instruments where
one can obtain even higher repeat
abilities but they are usually not
matter they thank you our next question
is for loss Higgins how difficult is it
to optimize reactions for
miniaturization let's say yeah that's a
really good question I can say that it
sort of varies a bit from a say to a say
but generally we don't encounter too
many asses that require extensive
optimization but when we do our
scientific team does have some support
capabilities to offer our customers to
help get those finicky asses tweaked for
use in a in a miniaturized format and
usually that can be pretty easily
addressed by an adjustment in the primer
concentration or sometimes in the
temperature settings of the PCR profile
itself
Quiroz and we have another question for
you do the benefits of automating qPCR
really outweigh the added costs yeah i
can say almost always brenda on the
surface lab automation is rarely thought
of as bargain equipment but when you
factor in the benefits of removing human
error from the process and the different
games and efficiency it becomes quite
clear that introducing laboratory
automation is economically advantageous
I can say the intelligible a step
further than typical lab automation
because we're reducing the reagent use
as well in addition to the efficiency in
the process so typically reactions may
go down to less than ten cents per
individual PCR reaction and in many
cases that huge savings justifies the
investment of the equipment almost
immediately
thank you our next question for Michael
this time from Dominic University of
Arizona are these results from technical
replicates of the same sample run on
different platforms in this in this
particular case it was run on a single
platform usually when one performs tests
on reproducibility one has to specify
what kind of reproducibility is being
tested and one can test for inter flight
reproducibility into run reproducibility
inter instrument reproducibility inter
lat reproducibility is it always has to
be specified but in this particular
example is run on a single instrument
great question next for Ross is there a
high learning curve with this device as
compared to others great question I
don't think we have too much of a
difference in our learning curve
although we are integrating liquid
handling and pcr pcr system into the
same unit so it is a bit more of a
complex unit than either of those
systems in a standalone format but it is
extremely easy to use we've designed the
software around a very user-friendly and
intuitive interface and with our on-site
training that's provided during the
installation as well as some additional
training for advanced users that's
offered at our company headquarters in
Alexandria Minnesota labs who adopt our
equipment will be very well equipped for
operating and troubleshooting the
machine great
our next question from James Keenan
ministries how often is the equipment QC
QA performed do you have specialized
analytical software for the equipment we
do routine preventative maintenance
plans but we we also work with
individual labs to determine the
maintenance schedule and the calibration
schedule that is suitable for their
particular application as well as any
regulatory requirements that might apply
in that particular lab environment as
far as software and tools we we have a
set of different tools in our software
that would be accessible to advanced
users as well as our service team to
help in terms of the calibrations and
other instrument maintenance functions
that might be needed over a period of
time thank you our next question also
for ross james from GSK asks can it be
used to quantify patient samples with
very low viral loads and I think I might
let Michael address this one as well but
yeah by and large the function of viral
load testing in a small reaction format
would be somewhat dependent upon the
titers expected for that particular
virus so whenever you reduce your
reaction volume you are also going to be
reducing the amount of copies that your
testing in that pcr reaction sometimes
that's may be handled by additional
replicates but in some cases the
necessary sensitivity for a given assay
wouldn't be a good candidate overall for
miniaturization and perhaps Michael can
can add some additional clarity to
applications that would be suitable for
miniaturization
well they're generally speaking if
you're only targeting one template so or
one target then essentially the
bottleneck will be the concentration how
to concentrate the material and if there
is a single molecule in that particular
reaction chamber you're going to detect
it if you're working with profiling
issues that you are looking for 20 you
perhaps 90 targets in a single sample
and you have to divide that central into
a loquats and usually those workflows
require a pre amplification of the
material and here the Intel acute has
quite an interesting advantage because
it's a high-throughput instrument but it
uses the little larger volumes than the
Icicle instruments are really
miniaturized which means that the number
of pre amplification cycles required us
is smaller so that that's actually a
pretty important advantage thank you for
those answers our next question or
michael hsu Bista could you explain in
more detail how you see tests of the two
pcr instruments board time the QC test
the QC test is done as follows it's it's
very very important when u QC that the
variation you observe is really due to
the instrument and not to the way you
pipette and or mix your samples or any
other factors that are not really
relevant so it's not little differently
on the intelligent than a conventional
qpcr instrument and that's because the
insula cube has integrated liquid
handling so the QC test on the
internship is actually testing the
combined performance of the liquid
handling and PCR which is
two more challenging because on a
regular can piece your instrument the QC
tests only the qpcr performance so
anyhow and what you do is that you work
with a highly reproducible say very well
working to say you have as large volumes
as possible because that's not what you
want to test for and then you played out
your samples such that all the wells
contain exactly the same material and we
just perform regular qpcr and you
analyze the variation of the signal
values typically this should be done
such that the cqs appear around 20 and
25 cycles which is where most
instruments perform the best so that's
typically standard procedure thank you
for that answer our next question also
actually for Ross will the reagents and
consumables from the Douglas scientific
be used on other vendor platforms or
vice versa yes so it depends a bit on on
which consumable we're discussing we we
do have our array tape consumable for
the PCR reactions that's the vessel
where the PCR reactions occur that
product is distributed by Douglas
scientific on the other hand there are
other consumables that might be used on
the instruments such as your sample
plate or your ass a plate or the pipette
tips that are used on the sample
dispensing head and those would be
sourced from a variety of other
manufactures
Thank You Ross my next question also for
Ross is question does the instrument
make the PCR mix for example taqman
reagent for cyber green typically the
lab operator will prepare a 2x reaction
mix of their asses for a given protocol
and that would be loaded into the
instrument in a plate format or it could
be in a tube format like matrix tubes
and essentially the instrument will load
800 nanometers of that reaction mixture
as well as 800 nanometers of the sample
or the nucleic acid template from the
sample plate to prepare a 1.6 microliter
total reaction Thank You Ross another
question for you John from internet
medicine asked is there online support
for this system absolutely we we have a
online service portal that's accessible
24 hours a day in 7 days a week and we
also have on-call phone support for
customers who may have a question or an
issue with the instrumentation
great our next question for dr. kubis
though you explain in more detail how he
cute seat tests of the qpcr instruments
were done I think I've had that question
before
okay great let's get to our next
question are there certain applications
for which miniaturization of PCR
reactions is not suitable I indeed
indeed there are and it actually relates
to a question yet earlier about viral
load testing and sensitivity and as Ross
answer and essentially you can you can
only detect what's in the tube in the
end and and of course if you miniaturize
analyzing very very small volumes that
will be the bottleneck in terms of
sensitivity because you need to
concentrate the original sample into
such a small volume and get the target
in there so those miniaturized platform
but I'm not really referring now to
Angelica because inside a cube is not
miniaturized to the extent as some of
the high folk would platforms like the
open array the food I'm biomark wave
which in the Rose 56 so that's
essentially where the interest by Fallon
are suitable for sensitive missions wait
thank you for that answer our next
question also for Michael
viral mutation I can occur fast and
often how is the instrument capable of
correcting for HIV and other mutations
yes I think that question might be best
answered by Michael but but my answer
would be that that would need to be
corrected on an assay basis rather than
on an instrumentation basis absolutely
that's that's the answer if it's it's an
assay issue it's not an instrumentation
thank you our next question is for Ross
do you think the liquid handling
component of Intel cube has made the
added advantage for precision of
pipetting replicants compared to other
platforms which increase the sensitivity
of resolution si yes absolutely you know
as you might guess anytime you have a
manual process that is handled from
different users in the lab or different
technicians you're going to be inherent
variability in their pipetting styles
and techniques some technicians are
exceedingly well with manual pipetting
and can sometimes be instruments but on
the other hand there are technicians in
the lab who are not as cautious with
their technique and would have CVS well
beyond what you would wish to have in a
sensitive qpcr assay and with the
entelechy the pipetting CVS are very
tight and we typically see CBS less than
four percent but always less than five
percent on the system
great thank you I think that is all the
time we have for questions I just want
to pass it back to Michael and Ross if
they have any further or final thoughts
for our audience Thank You Brenda and
thank you for all of you who have taken
time from your schedules this afternoon
this morning or this evening depending
on where you are to attend today's
webinar and we'd love to get in touch
with you if you'd like any additional
information you're also welcome to visit
our website douglas scientific calm
thank you for your time absolutely thank
you indeed and I if there is something
that you should bring home I think from
this seminar is the importance of
actually testing and validating your
particular instrument annual particular
say it's not that if achill it's not
expensive and there are tools to do it
now we also learned how to do it and
trust me you will find that some of your
instruments may not be performing as
well as the isma manufacturers crane
whereas you actually think they perform
so thank you again and if you're
interested in learning more alpha system
particularly hands on and visit our site
www.torrenting.com training thank you
gentlemen for your time in this
presentation we just want to let our
audience know that coming up you will
see two more full questions appear on
your screen as before if you could take
the time to answer these questions so we
can make sure that when you leave the
best content possible we would really
appreciate it we also want to let our
audience know but today's webcast is
available for elegant demand viewing
through March of 2016
and they'll be receiving an email from
labret when this webcast is available
for replay and we would love you to
format for would that announcement to
your colleagues if they were not able to
make today's live event again thank you
for your time thank you to Douglas
scientific we'll see you next time